you wrote an op-ed Reince Priebus HR
McMaster Steve Bannon then reached out
to you correct and they wanted to hear
more they wanted to hear more and then
weeks later they said okay figure out
what that actually costs give us a give
us a comparison and so rationalizing and
going down to a true battalion level
mentor program that supports the entire
Afghan army remember the Afghan Special
Forces works
there's about 17,000 of them because
they've been mentored by US Special
Forces in exactly the way I'm
recommending they used to do village
stability operations that works really
well again it was shut down by
conventional army tenants so so
mentoring the rest of the Afghan army in
that same proven model works second
given them some air
give them some governance supports that
when the battalions or to resupply they
get their food their fuel their
ammunition to their parts on time that's
what you need to keep the Afghan forces
afloat all the rest that goes from forty
five billion dollars spend this year
next year the Pentagon needs over fifty
billion dollars more than the entire UK
defense budget all that takes you down
to less than ten less than ten is what
you say what are you going back to the
Pentagon so so there's look there's a
lot of people that say just pull out of
Afghanistan I disagree with that because
I think the Taliban or Isis would raise
their battle flag over the u.s. embassy
in six months or a year that's bad but
continuing the same I would say insanity
that we've been doing for the last
sixteen years has to change I think the
president is uncomfortable with that
level with that
continuing on having woken to him are
not about battle so when you talk about
HR McMaster national security adviser
and Steve Bannon are you still talking
to them about these ideas the I would
say general McMaster does not like this
idea because he is a he is a three-star
conventional army general and he was
wedded to that idea that the US Army's
going to solve this but I think for the
president he's got to say after 16 years
when do we when do we try something
different and this in this here's the
thing the US isn't doing anything below
a core level right that's the highest
unit of movement of the Afghan army
they're not doing anything at the ground
level of the Afghan army so this can
operate there operate effectively and
create the off-ramp for the rest of US
forces to leave let's be done we're
still losing Americans there was two
American kids killed last week in the
first 30 days there
women enough so the abandon is more
receptive to this eventually man and
other other folks even an NSC and an
even quite a few in Congress